Here you see a circuit powered by a battery
and connected through a light bulb. This section
of the circuit is made from copper foil.
We can put a cut into the foil to make this
circuit incomplete. Taking advantage of the
thermal expansion properties of copper, we
can place some candles under the foil to provide
enough heat to expand the foil and complete
the circuit again! Many materials, like metals,
expand when you heat them.
But other materials, like polymers, shrink
when heated. The macroscopic properties of
both of these materials are highly dependent
on temperature.
The difference in the macroscopic behavior
of these two materials is determined by very
different microscopic structure. Statistical
Mechanics is the method used to describe and
predict behavior at the macro-scale based
on statistical models of microscopic behavior.
The first step to understanding the power
of Statistical Mechanics, is to use this method
to define and understand temperature in terms
of macro state parameters. The notion of equilibrium
will also prove to be useful in this exercise.
This video is part of the equilibrium video
series.
It is often important to determine whether
or not a system is at equilibrium. To do this,
we must understand how a system's equilibrium
state is constrained by its boundary and surroundings.
Hi, my name is Jeff Grossman, and I'm a professor
in the MIT Department of Materials Science
and Engineering.
Before watching this video, you should be
familiar with the second law of thermodynamics,
and the definitions of micro-state, macro-state,
and entropy.
After watching this video, you will be able
to: Explain how the definition of temperature
arises as a derivative of entropy with respect
to energy.
Consider an isolated, insulated box of non-interacting
particles. We can characterize this box macroscopically
by 3 parameters: the Volume of the box, the
Number of particles in the box (measured in
moles), and the total Energy. The Volume of
the box, and the Number of particles and the
total energy in this box are fixed. Thus a
microstate that corresponds to such a macrostate
is the velocity and position  of each
particle in the box. With this information,
we can determine the movement and position
of every particle in the box, and we obtain
the total energy is ½ mv^2 summed over all
particles. As you can imagine, measuring changes
in the system by tracking each and every microstate
would be a computational nightmare.
Instead, we consider Omega, the number of
microstates that correspond to a system with
macro-parameters E, N, and V. Now, let's consider
an isolated system comprised of two boxes
of non-interacting particles. The wall separating
the two boxes allows the transfer energy,
but does not allow particles to cross it.
What changes in macro state parameters do
we observe in our system? Pause the video
here. The volume and number of particles in
each box is fixed and unchanging. Because
energy, in the form of heat, can be transferred
through the wall, E1 and E2 can change. But
of course, the total energy E = E1 + E2 stays
the same, because the 2-box system is thermally
isolated. Let's count the total number of
microstates that the composite system can
have, which correspond to a total system energy
E. The easiest way to do this is to first
define a new function f(E1), which is the
number of microstates of the composite system
when box 1 has energy E1. To do this, we count
the number of microstates where box 1 has
some energy E1, and multiply this by the number
of microstates where box 2 has energy E-E1.
Then, to find the total number of microstates
for the composite system, we need to sum the
function f over all ways we could have selected
E1. We want to understand more about this
function f because it is key to defining Omega.
Let's look at a typical example to see what
f looks like.
We can explore the function f by considering
a simple case, where each particle can only
exist in one of 2 allowable energy states—one
with energy 0 and the other with 1. Suppose
I have 50 particles in box 1 and 100 particles
in box 2, and the total energy of the system
is fixed at, say, 50. In order to reach this
total energy, the energy E1 in box 1 can range
from 0 to 50. This is the graph for the number
of microstates with total energy E having
a given E1. We get this graph by looking at
all ways to assign every particle a 0 or 1
state such that the energy in box 1 is E1
and the energy in box 2 is E-E1. We can imagine
that the sum that defines omega is the area
under this graph.
Look at how peaked this graph is! With increasing
numbers of particles, the graph becomes more
and more strongly peaked. Remember, in a realistic
situation, the number of particles is going
to be on the order of Avagadro's number. Which
means the distribution of energies will be
highly peaked with a very small standard deviation.
Statistically, this means as the Number of
particles becomes larger, the energy in box
1 is almost always very close to this peak
value. Let's define Em to be the box 1 energy
corresponding to the peak value of f. So how
do we find Em? Pause the video and think about
it. To find Em, we want to maximize the function
f with respect to E1.
Since the volume, number, and total energy
of the system are fixed, differentiate f with
respect to E1. The maximum occurs when this
derivative is zero.
Take a moment to carry out this derivative,
and check your solution with ours. Pause the
video.
We obtain the following expression. Thus the
Energy Em that leads to the greatest number
of composite system microstates is defined
by this elegant condition.
So let's define a new macro-parameter, S,
called "entropy". The kB is Boltzmann's constant.
We'll explain why we include it later. By
defining this new term, entropy, our condition
above occurs when the derivative of the entropy
of box 1 with respect to the energy of box
1 is equal to the derivative of the entropy
of box 2 with respect to the energy of box
2.
So on average, we expect the energy of box
1 to be very close to Em. But what happens
if box 1 starts with some different energy,
maybe an energy significantly different from
Em? Statistically, because such a state is
so much less likely, when contact between
the boxes is made, the energy will redistribute
over time towards the most likely state, where
box 1 has energy Em.
This process of energy redistribution is called
equilibration. And the state with the highest
likelihood is called equilibrium!
How do we know we've landed in an equilibrium
state? If the derivative condition we found
earlier, evaluated at the average energy of
each box is held, it indicates that we are
at equilibrium. Note that in the simple example
scenario we considered earlier, it was NOT
the case that the energy of each box was the
same. It is the derivative of entropy with
respect to energy for each box evaluated at
the energy, number, and volume of each box
that must be equal at equilibrium.
This suggests that we should define the derivative
of entropy with respect to energy to be a
new system variable. But what would this variable
represent physically?
To figure out what it should be, think about
our composite system. The volume of each box
is constant as is the number of particles
in each box. The wall between the two boxes
allows energy to transfer. Over time, what
parameter will eventually be the same for
both boxes? Pause the video and discuss.
Our experience tells us that once 2 subsystems
are brought into thermal contact, we expect
the composite system will eventually evolve
so that each box has the same temperature!
But at equilibrium the derivative of entropy
with respect to energy of each box is also
equal. This tells us that this derivative
should be some function of temperature. In
fact, the derivative of entropy with respect
to energy is exactly equal to the reciprocal
of temperature! This tells us that when we
are measuring temperature of a system, we
are NOT measuring the energy of a system,
we are measuring this derivative!
There are specific units determined by the
typical way we measure temperature. This is
why Boltzmann's constant was introduced into
the definition of entropy! The constant is
introduced precisely so that the derivative
of entropy with respect to energy has dimension
of 1/temperature.
In this video we've seen that entropy is a
natural macrostate parameter, and statistically
a system's microstates evolve to exist within
the maximum entropy state. This is called
equilibrium. Temperature is naturally defined
as the derivative of entropy with respect
to energy for a system. And this definition
allows us to understand how temperature and
entropy are related at equilibrium.